congratulations the Culpo sisters it is
so cool getting a peek into your lives
tell me Aurora what is your role in this
family well I'm the boss so I basically
tell people what to do no I'm just
kidding um
when Aurora used to come down from her
room like you could hear the steps and
you were scared Olivia where do you fall
in this family well I am the middle
child and the stereotypes are true she
has the most issues I know she did get
left behind I did get left behind quite
a bit and then it's kind of funny that I
fell into this career which is basically
like you want me to say seeking
validation from the internet
I would say I'm the glue and backbone of
the family right baby of the family yes
okay tell me about your role I think any
younger sibling can relate to always
being the younger sibling and therefore
your opinion matters slightly less so
you're taken seriously slightly less so
but that's just like yeah
if we don't yeah consider it do you
notice also whenever I talk the two of
them both go
every time they're like you're saying
something right wrong I don't know I can
already tell that you know we're gonna
get a real window into this sister
Dynamic on this show and I think you
guys know reality TV is a mixed bag it
can come with UPS Downs everything in
between why ultimately did you decide to
open the door let the world in and
expose your personal lives in this very
cool raw kind of way there's so many
things about it I feel like we've always
been open books to a certain extent and
the other thing about having a big
family that's so insulating so I feel
like there's a lot of comfort with that
like kind of just like knowing that
we're in this together and whatever
happens we still have each other we love
each other we trust each other we are
each other's best friends like if the
world doesn't like us it's not gonna
hurt that bad like you know I feel like
we're we all we've all like kind of been
canceled a little bit here and there
before so we know what it feels like
that's fine but like we're we're good
yeah
and also we do feel like there's an
importance and there's a need for
vulnerability and for honesty and I feel
like that's something that we are really
good at at and that we've kind of
harnessed it was an amazing opportunity
and we were not going to say no to it in
our family there's no boundaries
there's no filter very inappropriate
and there's no shortage of drama with
having a co-ep credit was anything off
limits did you say don't film me here
this is where I draw the line I'm not
talking about that topic we chose our
showrunner and from the get-go we made
sure it was a relationship that we knew
there was a mutual respect and Trust we
had to kind of trust her expertise in
knowing that she knows how to make a
great show and we needed to give the
vulnerability that we promised we would
give so that's yeah I think we both kept
our end of the bargain honestly there
was really nothing off limits three
stunning sisters inevitably there are
some comparisons to another famous
family the Kardashians have you guys
heard this what do you make of it is it
a compliment or is it something that
you're like you know what we're doing
our own thing the thing that this show
highlights honestly is the juxtaposition
between our life in LA and then where we
came from in Rhode Island and that's
just a really special perspective that
no show out there has yeah and the
people we came from and our parents are
just yeah our queers are quirky they're
just you're gonna fall in love with them
but it's just it couldn't be more
different I think the only similar is
that yes we're sisters and there are
three of us but that doesn't make for a
similar similar shows or lives or
sisters yeah and we like to be compared
to successful people so 100 powerful
women we will take what we yeah we got
to see a little Christian in the show we
got a little face time between you and
him and I love that you said you swore
you'd never date another athlete I'm
curious why is Christian the exception
oh he's just the best I feel like he is
really everything that I could ever ask
for
um just so I never have to worry about
anything and I think that was the reason
why I didn't want to date an athlete no
offense because there is reputation
there for reasons he comes from a great
family we have a lot in common in that
respect he has a really good head on his
shoulders and like he's hot too right
you said you really want to be a mom in
the next two to three years is that
something that you and like Christian
have conversations about and you're on
the same page about yeah every couple is
going to have those conversations I
can't tell you exactly when but I wish I
could nobody knows when I'm excited for
the future I have no exact timeline but
it will be really great I loved your
producer asks you a question about a
form of relationship you were in and you
have this like very visceral reaction
you're like I don't even talk about that
I love that you called it a formative
experience so when you think back on
that experience he's a dad now you're in
a wonderful relationship your career is
thriving like what was your biggest
lesson learned from that relationship
but relationships are like putting a
mirror up to yourself you see things
about yourself that you need to work on
it it really requires you to turn inward
in a real in a weird way of course when
they fail it's not a whole other level
so I feel like I learned a lot about
myself in every single hiccup in life
and with every single person that
involves so you can only be grateful for
those type of experiences Sophie let's
move on to you Olivia said that she
swore she'd never date another athlete
did you ever feel that way I did I
actually swore after one of her past
relationships I also said I would never
date an athlete and it's something that
I feel guilty about now saying that
because you seem so happy I'm so happy
and Christian and Braxton are truly such
amazing people and outside of just not
for an athlete compared to any guy out
there he's one of the most genuine and
kind Souls that I've ever met so to say
say that at one point I was like oh I
never did nothing I just feel so bad
about that because I fell to the
stereotype that they rise stereotypes
happen for a reason but it's not right
to say because Christian and Braxton are
just amazing people so saying that here
I am I ended up dating an athlete I
broke my own rule you want to be a mom
in the next like two-ish three-ish years
do you have those conversations I think
I would never go into a relationship
without at least knowing
um or is our kids something that you
want yeah it's something that we both
agreed on but we're in no rush Aurora it
seems like your relationship is kind of
going on a journey is that fair to say
ah well the journey ended really okay I
mean no we are not married anymore we're
friends and we have two kids together so
we get along and we're making it work
but the show really captures the like
Pinnacle of all of that drama and so
there were cameras around for that whole
period of Time how does it feel watching
all of that very personal stuff play out
on TV has it been emotional for you
having to like go back and watch the
episodes and sort of relive those more
painful yeah I mean I remember certain
moments that were really hard that the
cameras were there for and I'm just like
I'm a little nervous to watch it back
it's hard to go through it and it's hard
to trust that you're that you're doing
everything the right way for everybody
that's involved I think I did the best
job I could but I'm just hoping that
everybody's happy with the way the final
product turned out because you know it's
not just my story to tell and I want to
respect him and my kids and I think we
did it really Tastefully are you dating
now is there anybody special in your
life no I'm not dating I think that it's
important for me to just kind of not
date for a little while yeah I think I
need to be like just in a in a
relationship with myself and learning
why it is that like you know I
manifested a relationship that that
ultimately was not the right one for me
and I want to make sure I'm not um just
kind of attracting another one of those
the premiere episode ends with you
revealing that you enabled your your
former partner to have a hall pass once
a year yes now knowing what you know is
that something that you would allow in
the future no no definitely not that was
something that we agreed on 10 years ago
and I just feel like I'm an evolved
person now not that it's unevolved to be
that way but I know that for me it
doesn't work so okay that won't be
happening in the next relationship
we're all super close I love you guys
cheers even though sometimes we want to
kill each other
season two are you guys down oh yeah
yeah yeah you loved it you're
experiencing it into existence I mean do
we love this every moment of this
experience no it was hard grueling and
scary but I think ultimately we'll look
back on these like coveted Home Videos
truly yeah people don't understand how
much work and it's like it's a lot of
therapy we're forced to make resolutions
to all of our conflicts things that we
normally would rush under the rug we're
like wait we have to talk about that why
[Music]
foreign